y
hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 es tramitada de hoy es para tu
ayuda
por unos días más es la fiscal jefe de
la corte penal internacional y 15 de
junio dejará su cargo después de 9 años
gracias por estar con nosotros desde
largas
muchas gracias por invitarme
señora vencida acaba de regresar de su
último viaje antes de dejar su cargo y
esto en un lugar muy simbólico para la
cpi
por primera vez según tengo entendido
durante décadas zuma fue considerado
tales como el ejemplo de las
limitaciones de la cpi había una orden
de arresto contra el entonces presidente
omar al-bashir sin embargo éste viajó
por áfrica durante diez años no obstante
hace dos años fue derrocado por una
revuelta popular
y ahora está encarcelado usted
evidentemente ha discutido sobre su
posible traslado a la cpi por las
autoridades de la transición va a ir
omar al bachir a la allá en algún
momento
en primer lugar le diré que esta fue una
visita muy histórica y muy importante
para el trabajo de la cpi
y como usted lo dijo esta es una
situación que era realmente muy urgente
para nosotros y la justicia penal
internacional porque investigamos una
vez que se nos lo pide y usted vio todas
las dificultades y la politización que
tuvimos en el caso de ayudantes pero las
cosas son diferentes ahora hay un nuevo
gobierno en el poder inmediatamente esto
sucedió pudimos aprovechar la
oportunidad de comprometer al nuevo
gobierno
verán que también por primera vez
tuvimos la oportunidad de
complementariedad y todo lo que el
estatuto de roma nos permite aproveche
la oportunidad de ir a su dante y me
reuní con las autoridades esto fue desde
octubre del año pasado y la semana
pasada volví hace unos días y tuve la
oportunidad de visitar las comunidades
afectadas poder hablar con ellos poder
interactuar con ellos y también
gestionar las expectativas que tienen
pero también asegurarles que se hará
justicia y que la cpi nunca
abandonado ni abandonará como víctimas
de estos crímenes así que era
particularmente importante enviar ese
mensaje y especialmente tener esa
interacción y tener la interacción y ver
la luz y live con lo que está sucediendo
en los campamentos
y estoy segura de que vio las imágenes
de que ellos mismos siempre han buscado
justicia y no han perdido la esperanza
así que creo que estamos en un lugar más
útil que antes también pude reunirme con
las autoridades y entre nuestras
conversaciones estaba la entrega de
quienes han sido acusados por la cpi
las órdenes de captura que están
pendientes de la ejecución de esas horas
hablé con ellos y por supuesto el ex
presidente omar al-bashir es uno de los
que tiene una orden de arresto pendiente
y hablamos de eso y todavía no hemos
tenido una respuesta definitiva al
respecto world
pero ciertamente las autoridades de
sudán están dispuestas a participar en
las conversaciones
y ver cuáles son las mejores medidas que
podemos tomar para garantizar que se
haga justicia
entonces existe la posibilidad de que
vaya a la haya cree que es una
posibilidad real en un futuro muy
cercano
es una posibilidad pero como lo dije
antes todavía no se ha concretado nada
debe haber un diálogo debe haber un
compromiso porque obviamente debido al
principio de complementariedad los
mismos sudaneses también lo piensan que
es un derecho que tienen bajo el
estatuto de roma si están dispuestos y
son capaces de investigar y procesar
así que todas estas son posibles
discusiones que están en curso acerca de
la situación en darfur
quiero pasar a costa de márfil el ex
presidente de lauren bacall anunció que
volverá a su país el 17 de junio
eso ocurre unos meses después de su
absolución definitiva lo cual es
probablemente uno de sus mayores
fracasos
de nuevo no quiero aceptar que esto sea
un fracaso desafilió
como es un fracaso en el sentido de que
lo que hemos intentado hacer como
institución que ha exigido hacerlo es
investigar y perseguir los crímenes
especialmente en nombre de las víctimas
que han sufrido software
y dirá que no ha muerto gente en costa
de marfil después de esa violencia nadie
dirá que no se han cometido crímenes de
hecho
incluso los jueces que finalmente se
pronunciaron coincidieron en que
efectivamente se cometieron crímenes en
costa del partido por lo tanto no
estamos allí solo para procesar a un
líder
estamos allí para hacer justicia que es
nuestro objetivo por lo tanto no creo
que sea justo decir que esto es un
fracaso los jueces decidieron finalmente
que mi responsabilidad como fiscal era
asegurarme de que siguiera todo el
proceso para tratar de hacer justicia
hasta el final y eso es lo que hago solo
cumplí con mi deber con mi
responsabilidad tal y como lo dicta el
estatuto de roma y que hay de sus
repetidas promesas de que se
investigaría a la otra parte entre
comillas
me refiero a que lo ha dicho en
repetidas ocasiones aquí en otros
lugares pero no pasa nada
pasará y realmente para investigar el
mando
una vez más insistir en que
efectivamente tal y como lo prometí
desde el principio también hay una costa
de marfil y se está investigando esta
situación esto no es una mentira no es
una promesa que acabo de hacer así como
así hemos estado investigando y por
supuesto que hemos tenido desafíos con
respecto a esta investigación en el
sentido de que tuvimos la pandemia
también tuvimos otros problemas que nos
impidieron tal vez hacerlo todo a la
velocidad que hubiéramos querido
pero puedo decirles que esas
investigaciones en particular también
han avanzado significativamente y
también se trata de costa de marfil de
la que he hablado todo el tiempo tal vez
no esté todavía en posición de hacer un
anuncio público sobre lo que está
ocurriendo pero puedo asegurar que
también se han realizado investigaciones
en la situación de costa de marfil que
están significativamente avanzadas
significa que en el momento adecuado
esté yo o no
se hará público el resultado de esa
investigación de investigación supe me
hable incluyendo las órdenes de arresto
los resultados se harán públicos muy
rápidamente porque no tenemos mucho
tiempo hablemos de gas el aumento de la
violencia en comparación con las
anteriores rondas de violencia desde el
pasado mes de marzo se abrió una
investigación oficial que fue muy
debatida las autoridades israelíes el
primer ministro han dicho que esto es
puro antisemitismo están estudiando de
cerca el asunto mientras hablamos
sin vida
efectivamente me remito a una
declaración que hice en un tuit
públicamente cuando empezó la violencia
me uní a la comunidad internacional para
pedirles calma y contención a ambas
partes sobre lo que estaba ocurriendo en
gaza
pero también aproveché la ocasión para
recordar que tras pedir aclaraciones y
obtener las de los jueces de la cpi
se han abierto investigaciones sobre la
situación en gaza
por lo tanto vamos a investigar todos
los crímenes que son competencia de la
cpi
al menos desde 2014 también he
aprovechado para informar que los
acontecimientos actuales que se están
produciendo en la guerra de los 11 días
como es llamada ahora que todos esos
acontecimientos también formarán parte
de nuestras investigaciones
así que ya lo he dicho públicamente en
esto estamos como saben después de que
los jueces nos dieran claridad respecto
a nuestra jurisdicción en la situación
de palestina anuncia públicamente
que las investigaciones están abiertas y
las investigaciones están en curso ahora
mismas
ah
como resultado de su actuación en
palestina así como en afganistán la
administración trump le impuso sanciones
que éstas ya fueron levantadas en
retrospectiva fue este su momento más
difícil como fiscal cuando eeuu decidió
imponerle sanciones
a mí me sancionaron por hacer mi trabajo
legítimo y eso me creó problemas sobre
todo operativos pero no me impidió hacer
el trabajo que debía hacer
y eso es algo que todo el mundo puede
ver si tú antes de 70
debajo de aforo y estamos muy contentos
realmente acogemos con satisfacción la
idea de que la administración vaivén
haya decidido levantar estas sanciones
dos tantos andando
y que tanto la cpi como la
administración estadounidense quieren
que volvamos a comprometernos porque
debo decir que antes de estas sanciones
antes de la administración trump
a pesar de que eeuu no es un estado que
haga parte del estatuto de roma siempre
hemos tenido una muy buena relación de
trabajo jeannette
hemos cooperado y es funcionó en el
pasado hasta el desafortunado
acontecimiento que tuvo lugar durante la
era trump
[Música]
y quiere volver a comprometerse al igual
que eeuu lo que han dicho públicamente
en varias ocasiones y definitivamente
esperamos que esa nueva colaboración se
base en el respeto mutuo y en un diálogo
constructivo estamos preparados para
esto muy rápidamente tengo entendido que
ha estado observando la situación en
venezuela muy de cerca será abierta la
investigación sobre esa situación antes
de que se vaya
me referiré aquí a mi último informe de
examen preliminar en el que explicó en
qué punto nos encontramos para la
situación de venezuela siempre he
indicado que hemos estado en el proceso
de examinar la situación allí
y que se han cumplido la mayoría de los
criterios que se necesitan para que la
fase de examen preliminar termine esto
también es de dominio público y pueden
ver
sin embargo recientemente estoy segura
de que lo vieron
venezuela se comprometió con la cámara
para decir que la cámara debería
intervenir con respecto a nuestro examen
preliminar
y también porque no están recibiendo la
cooperación que necesitan de la oficina
lo cual les debo decir con todo el
respeto es incorrecto me he comprometido
mi oficina se ha comprometido
ampliamente con venezuela- sensible
incluso con las más altas autoridades
que se comprometen con nosotros y eso es
lo que hemos estado haciendo y este es
un asunto que también daremos a conocer
a la cámara eso no quita el hecho de que
he avanzado significativamente en la
situación de venezuela
y esperamos poder después de esta
declaración ante los jueces tendremos
que decidir no puedo decir más al
respecto
pero después de esta declaración también
estaremos en condiciones de hacer
públicas nuestras conclusiones sobre
venezuela muy rápidamente se nos acaba
el tiempo que sigue para usted la
presidencia de gambia tal vez
ante todo creo que es así que me voy a
tomar un tiempo ya estuve
para relajarme y ordenar mis
pensamientos pero como siempre digo me
concentraré en la cpi hasta el último
día
hasta que deje esta oficina como fiscal
y después ya veremos fatou bensouda
ahora quiero agradecerle o nunca por
haberle concedido france24 una de sus
últimas entrevistas antes de dejar su
cargo y gracias a todos ustedes por
verla
[Música]